pop
[Musique]
venu au pied du mur
aujourd'hui nous accueillons alexandre
rognon
monique frémit
jean marc levy
et christine carrère
piloter ce nouveau jeu tout en images
retrouvons julien lepers
[Applaudissements]
oui oui je suis heureux mais vraiment
heureux de vous retrouver à un horaire
inhabituel un jour inhabituel c'est le
dimanche passé un bon dimanche en notre
compagnie c'est le numéro un de ce
nouveau jeu donc bienvenue sur ce
plateau de pied du mur et je vous
signale que dans un moment c'est vous
qui serait au pied du mur il va falloir
retrouver les documents vous connaissez
vous aimez la télévision la preuve c'est
que vous êtes là entre la regarde et on
va vous passez des documents historiques
récents drôle
émouvant sportif il faudra les
identifier il faudra aller reconnaître
alors attention la règle du jeu vous
allez à comprendre tout au long des
missions on peut pas faire plus ça c'est
la première manche au pied du mur et
bondy montre à tous
voilà la première manche
la première manche depuis les murs les
cas candidats sont là vous les
connaissez enfin on vous les avez
présenté rapidement tout à l'heure il va
falloir que vous identifier les trois
documents vous allez voir maintenant sur
cet immense mur d'image vous connaissez
ces images sont des images classiques je
dirais incontournable à vous de jouer
aussi chez vous je compte sur vous au
pied du mur le premier document à
découvrir attention un top images
oui oui monique je suis à vous les
départs du queen elizabeth
ça n'est pas non non ça n'est pas du
tout la bonne réponse pouvait plus jouer
pour ce tour là j'attends les trois
autres candidats et on continue de
l'image
oui je dirais la première traverse ses
diplômes aux france c'est une mauvaise
réponse désolé en continu top l'image
doublé
oui alexandre la visite de grace kelly à
monaco
ça n'est pas la bonne réponse en continu
des images s'il vous plaît
jean-marc le mariage de graisse et
rainier de monaco voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est une très bonne réponse
effectivement c'était le mariage du
prince rainier et de grace kelly parmi
des invités au mariage religieux y avait
sa masse est môme la duchesse de
westminster aristote onassis et sa femme
tina il y avait là gars quand la bégum
gloria swanson et ava gardner aussi ami
et ancien partenaire de grace kelly et
au mariage civil la veille c'est le
ministre de la justice qui représentait
la france était françois mitterrand
voilà premier document on s'arrête là je
vois qu'on applaudisse encore sylvain
jean marc
plus que trois candidats et un deuxième
document vous jouez chez vous et moi je
donne encore une fois à table images
regarder
alexandre je suis la construction de la
fusée ariane
c'est une mauvaise réponse réponse
refusé on continue avec les images
regardez les bien
[Musique]
oui monique le lancement de la fusée
ariane
complétez votre réponse s'est doublé le
lowe's le premier lancement de la fusée
ariane en guyane française
non répondent
refusé
en continu des images regardez bien
alexandre le premier essai de la fusée
ariane
non
la bonne réponse images
oui mais c'est les premiers lancements
de satellites par la fusée ariane ça
n'est pas la bonne réponse est non
tables images
oui la mise en orbite du premier
satellite français
ce n'est pas la réponse que je demande
en continu l'image
[Musique]
allez allez allez vous utiliser tout
suivi
la mise en orbite de tes dessins pour la
fusée ariane non pas du tout
les marges non
blick le lancement de la fusée apollo
[Musique]
côté d'une image
s'est terminé bon mes enfants vous avez
tourné autour parce que bon on m'a parlé
d'ariane c'était ça effectivement ça
c'était le premier lancement d'ariane 4
et oui alors tiens une question puisque
personne ne trouve et on va essayer vous
départager il faut qu'ils aient un des
candidats ou des candidates qu'il soit
qualifié pour la manche suivante alors
une question vous avez 15 secondes de
réflexion
donnez moi s'il vous plaît l'année du
premier lancement d'ariane 4 15 secondes
on réfléchit
j'écoute monique 1963 non la
ja bus et
cassé une 1990 non ce n'est pas la bonne
réponse
alors vous auriez pu répondre quelque
chose
alexandre c'était le moment ou jamais
non la bonne réponse était 1988 alors
quelle est la réponse la plus approchant
des basses et christine kristin qui est
qualifié voilà
je me retrouve au pied du mur dans un
instant ici
il ne reste plus que deux candidats avec
un dernier document tab images
[Musique]
alexandre la fabrication d'une voiture
mauvaise réponse
image
une explication d'une fusée
non je regrette
images regardez bien
observer des moindres détails alexandre
une simulation de pilotage non pas du
tout la
l'image
oui l'essai du niveau d'un moteur de
voiture de course
complétez votre réponse mené formule 1
d'un moteur de formule 1
complétez votre réponse
l'essai d'un moteur d'une formule heures
depuis la fabrication jusqu'à aux essais
techniques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors résultats de cette première manche
les trois candidats sont qualifiés ça y
est nous jouons avec eux dans un moment
je suis désolé alexandra je voudrais
c'est très grave non non c'est pas grave
vous viendrez pour un autre jeu un autre
pied du mur d'accord sur mon rendez vous
bientôt à la prochaine en tout cas l'ex
ans des cadeaux pour vous regardez les
ils sont ajoutés une citation quand même
parti en tête à tête pour un week end
chez campanile et retrouver
l'authenticité d'une auberge moderne tel
accueil des patrons chez campanile ça
sent bon la tradition
vous emporte également offert par
éditions atlas un abonnement à je joue
la musique que j'aime nouvelles méthodes
pour chanter et jouer les grands tubes
[Musique]
félicitations jean bart pour cette
première qualification merci beaucoup
nous inclinons vraiment vous avez une
quarantaine d'années oui vous êtes
ingénieur commercial c'est un peu vague
nous dit mme en plus je vends des stages
de micro-informatique d'accord et puis
en dehors de ça vous avez un hobby oui
conserver les jeunes loups vous avez des
choses vous avez des courses de chevaux
j'aime beaucoup les courses de chevaux
mais je ne joue pas même pas une petite
pièce non pas du tout a beaucoup coûté
bien je vous expliquer la marche à
suivre et pour tout le monde aussi nous
sommes ici en deuxième manche
le candidat qui est ici jean marc est
pile face à un immense mur d'image et
les deux autres candidats qui sont là
eux ne voient pas ces images
vous avez de vider ce que vous allez
devoir faire jean marc lui refaire de
mai exactement le document pourra faire
défiler maintenant sur ce grand mur
d'image vous aurez 45 secondes maximum
bien sûr et si vous arrivez vous
marquerez un point jean marc et vous
ferez marque est aussi un point celle à
celle des deux candidats qui aura deviné
ce document je pense que c'est clair
maintenant c'est la deuxième manche qui
commence bonne chance jean-marc alléger
un laissez vous aller le document tom
image
alors nous sommes on voit des chameaux
ça peut être dans un désert ou dans dans
un pays arabe je ne sais pas peut-être
on voit des hommes avec le long d'une
palissade qui sont en train de
construire quelque chose ou deux
peut-être reconstruire quelque chose on
voit des pierres qui semble être des
pierres dans une pyramide je pense
qu'ils sont en train de mettre des
pierres peut-être de faire là
d'arranger la pyramide les anciennes
pyramide peut-être avec des échafaudages
on dirait que c'est le caire c'est la
première fois que je vois le sphinx et
qu'ils sont en train d'arranger la
pyramide du sphinx monique la réparation
de la pyramide et du sphinx et je viens
moi je dis que c'est une réponse
complète compléter votre réponse aux
knicks
réparation du sein voilà ça c'est
les i7 d'arriver quand ben
alors vous marquez un point et j'ai une
question bonus si vous répondez à cette
question je vous posais maintenant oui
et qui a un rapport direct avec le
document qu'on vient de voir débarquer
un point de plus question bonus qu'elles
et vous aurez 15 secondes de réflexion
quel pharaon a fait construire la grande
pyramide 15
[Applaudissements]
pompes akhenaton non
construite en 2005 180 avant jésus
christ est l'une des sept merveilles
du monde qui mesure 167 mètres de
hauteur alors voilà vous allez rejoindre
le mur d'image dans un moment vous avez
un point ce qui est déjà pas si mal mon
cher jean marc et pendant ce temps là la
suite du document la restauration du
sphinx donc ce colosse monstrueux aux
proportions imposantes assemblée et puis
évident et dans un grade dur avec un
grain compact comme les granits égyptien
ce sphinx veille sur la grande pyramide
voilà c'est terminé un point pour jean
martin peu d'applaudir une nouvelle fois
d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
ça va que si ça va oui alors ma chère
christine vous avez compris ce qu'il
fallait faire ça en deuxième manche de
nos pied du mur je n'en dis pas plus
vous jouez chez vous tab image
alors on voit un étal de marché ça a
l'air d'être assez anciens parce que
c'est en noir et blanc décoder ménagères
du conte en marché des fruits des
légumes une vieille balance un garçon
qui appuient tufin qui m'aidait
apparemment c'est des tickets de
rationnement
là on est dans un librairies sont des
jeunes enfants qui vivent là on est à la
poste
monsieur ouvre son courrier il a l'air
très surpris là on voit des vendanges
apparemment il ya un monsieur qui prend
une note de raisin on voit des vieux
billets de banque avec les filles vols
de gol enfin de faire un discours on
voit d'un bon oeil monique une réponse
monique le rationnement pendant la
guerre non c'est pas du tout la bonne
réponse on continue notre image
l'apparent manque quelqu'un qui regarde
des pièces de monnaie repart à manger
mais un changement datant des attardés
temps des gendarmes jouer c'est la
création du franc lourd
c'est une bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
bravo à tous les deux très bonne
description christine qui a fait
découvrir jean-marc en fait c'était la
mise en circulation du nouveau franc ou
du franc lourd c'est la même chose très
bien question bonus 15 secondes de
réflexion testing pour doubler votre
score remarqué un poids mais si vous
voulez a marqué deux regardez et notez
bien cette question quel ministre quel
ministre des finances c'est facile à
préparer la mise en circulation du
nouveau franc laisser mon pardon pas de
bva
entre les deux murs dans un instant et
la suite du document il nous reste
encore quelques secondes la banque de
france y met en circulation
de nouveaux types de billets libellés en
nouveau france en nouveaux francs 50
veaux france un nouveau front aussi
coupure imprimé sur les mêmes vignettes
que les billets libellés en francs à
l'éffigie de bonaparte henri iv
richelieu et victor hugo bravo jean marc
c'était bien la mise en circulation du
nouveau projet qu'on vous applaudissent
une nouvelle corde
[Applaudissements]
walkom monique bienvenue sur ce plateau
de cette première émission au pied du
mur sur france 3 tous les dimanches à
13h45 vous hanter bienvenus oui très
bien joli de savoir quand j'ai envie
d'en savoir un peu plus sur vous qui
êtes vous vraiment ben je travaille au
bureau d'aidé sociale de la ville de
paris je fais beaucoup de natation de
l'aquagym avec toutes les collègues de
l'aquagym avec les collègues oui à la
piscine du quartier je fais beaucoup de
photos également vous et la télévision
oui bien sûr les jeux tous les jeux wii
voilà c'est pour ça qu'on est là
évidemment monique alors vous savez ce
qui vous reste à faire maintenant c'est
de faire découvrir le document le sujet
que vous allez voir que vous allez voir
aussi chez vous c'est pas si facile que
ça alors je vous laisse avec ce sujet à
vous de vous débrouiller 45 secondes
d'attention top image
alors il ya beaucoup de nuages on ne
voit que le ciel il ya vraiment des
nuages court très vite il ya des
tornades et à s'en portent tous la
tornade et maison c'est que c'était jour
je dirais le cyclone en floride
non ce n'est pas la bonne réponse
on continu des images
vraiment tout est dévasté envoie les
maisons on voit à l'infini à l'infini il
n'y a que de la désolation jean-marc la
bombe atomique sur hiroshima non non
non non
à écouter bien écoutez bien la
description de monique top images
c'est vraiment un ouragan il emporte
tout et voilà la tornade avec l'oeil le
centre d'hadji tornade sur la le cyclone
hugo en guadeloupe
non non non
on continue il nous reste du temps docu
beaurivage
tout est démoli tout est vraiment ravagé
en voilà le grand radars qui essayent de
découvrir exactement le centre de ce
cyclone qui dévaste tout c'est vraiment
la voile à l'impact il l'a vraiment en
pleine ville ça se passe aux etats unis
c'est vraiment attention jean-marc c'est
le tremblement de terre à san francisco
non pas du tout
non pas du tout il nous reste quelques
petites secondes de documents cycle à
écouter biache tabib aja les hippies le
cyclone andrew qui vient de passer sur
les antilles non mauvaise réponse et on
continu des images
il a ravagé une partie des états unis et
là on voit c'est terminé à 1
moi je pense que c'était une bonne
description jean-marc il fallait être un
petit peu perspicace et écrit si on est
aussi imposé plusieurs c'était la
création d'une barrière de radars
convoyés à un moment où il rate un
contre les tornades aux états unis
c'était sympa non c'est ainsi que ça on
s'arrête là et vous pouvez rejoindre le
mur
les jeux sont faits
jean-marc deux points
jean-marc sera avec nous pour la
troisième et dernière manche christine
deux points voilà je veux dire le face à
face en fait ils seront côte à côte et
je vous expliquerai pourquoi dans un
moment donné vous vous asseyez parce que
je vais vous offrir de beaux cadeaux
maintenant je pense que ça va vous faire
plaisir vous quittez le jeu certes mais
vous souviendrez de ce premier passage
au pied du mur sur france 3 et allez
c'est cadeau du parti pour un week end à
douchez compagnie dé retrouver
l'authenticité et la saveur d'une
auberge de tradition avec ses chambres
chaleureuses c'est buffet à volonté et
ses petits plats du patron
vous emporte également offert par
éditions atlas seconde atlas
encyclopédique de l'europe une véritable
initiation à l'europe
[Musique]
ils sont là
[Applaudissements]
jean marc et christine les deux derniers
candidats les finalistes finalement du
jeu nous arrivons maintenant à la
troisième manche d'eau pied du mur tout
le monde est au pied du mur et vous
aussi la falloir essayer de suivre cette
troisième manche avec attention
l'explication le règlement est très
simple vous allez voir chacun et chacune
document différence et christine qui va
commencer d'ailleurs document spécial
pour vous il va falloir que vous le
décrivez en fournissant le maximum de
détails
vous fassiez une description très
complète précise et presque
journalistique du document vous allez
voir et que dans cette description vous
me donniez quatre mots les quatre mots
qui s'inscrivent au bas de vos écrans
télévision sur france3 premier document
c'est donc christine qui joue tout seul
quatre mots mystères à prononcer bonne
chance top images
on voit des gens à cheval on voit des
officiels apparemment se passe en inde
apparemment c'est lady di là on voit un
superbe palais lady di toujours habillé
de rouge qui se promène dans un jardin
et didier habillés en bleu avec un
superbe chapeau bleu et blanc
l'apparemment elle est en train de dire
bonjour à des autochtones en train de
faire le prince charles qui empruntent
fani palli partie de polo cheval
un
tramway ou en autobus qui arrive dans
complètement surpeuplé là on voit lady
di avec mère teresa ou des petites
soeurs de la paix ou des choses comme ça
il ne faudrait bien saisir un enfant
apparemment lady di toujours avec un
collier de fleurs autour du cou avec
mère teresa
[Musique]
sur la fin du document il y avait mes
teresa bien sûr mais il y avait des
religieuses derrière elle et le mot
religieuse était très important mais
vous n'avez pas prononcé christine il
était dans la liste des quatre
mouvements religieuses vous avez trois
sur quatre vous aviez de point bas donc
voilà ça vous fait 5.6 gelabale on
applaudit christine s'il vous plaît
c'était
le voyage officiel de lady di et du
prince de galles en inde quatre mots
nouveaux documents pour vous jean-marc
quatre mots à prononcer attention aux
images c'est parti on doit mourir
chevalier qui son canotier avec un
papillon des gens qui regardent toujours
des canotiers boivent une tasse de café
morishita qui sont assis sur une chaise
une balancelle vaguement télévision une
caméra des danseuses avec leur tutu leur
pointure à l'opéra vraisemblablement
toujours chevalier avec martine carol
avec son collier de perles avec une
fourrure qui sont assis sur une chaise
sur des fauteuils
marque toujours meurtri au piano il joue
il joue au piano il est ambassadeur
on voit des dames sur dans un an à new
york ils sont près troyes new york à
paris on lui remet un oscar
un trophée ensuite voilà la reine la
reine d'angleterre à qui on remet un
canotier géant à maurice chevalier il
est avec d'autres personnes il ya un
gâteau d'anniversaire ans une coupe le
gâteau avec un penneteau la vdn
ça m'a plu ça c'était une très belle
description bravo je crois qu'il faut
c'est ça que je il faut dire le maximum
de mots on sait jamais vous pouvez
tomber juliet redevient trois bons mots
c'est ce que vous avez trouvez vous y
trouvez piano c'était bon au tout début
je crois ensuite il y avait qu'à dossier
super évidemment maurice chevalier
canotiers d'accord le gâteau à la fin et
puis il y avait un autre mot c'était de
mon ballerines roger danseuses et oui
c'était ballerines n'était pas loin mais
enfin ce n'était pas tout à fait ça on a
un cas de figure intéressant sainte foy
pour christine jean marc cinq points on
applaudit les deux candidats s'ils
voulaient
c'était c'étaient les 75 ans de maurice
chevalier prospère youplaboum ma pomme
et tout ça fabuleux maurice chevalier
très bien alors égalité 5-5 tout va se
jouer maintenant sur cette question
c'est le jeu décisif tie break ou pour
ceux qui aiment bien l'anglais jeu
décisif
une question 15 secondes de réflexion
c'est le premier ou la première qui
donne la bonne réponse qui l'emportent
qui gagnent de cette première édition de
pied du mur qui passera donc un bon
dimanche question en quelle année
maurice chevalier at il eu 75 ans
c'est christine joue d'abord que c'est
1959 connais pas la bonne réponse
1963 jean bart 1963 s'élabore de combat
super c'est vous qui remporté cette
première édition de pied des murs
vraiment oiseaux 1963
en 1963 pour un chevalier a eu 75 ans
alors bravo jean marc bravo christine
des cadeaux pour les deux candidats que
voici regarder
avec ce week-end pour déchets contenus
visibles aux points du film et vous vous
réveillerez dans un cadre verdoyant
retrouvant l'authenticité d'une auberge
mode est
également offert par éditions atlas un
abonnement 80 numéros des génies de la
musique pour une nouvelle écoute de la
musique classique est pour le vainqueur
d'aujourd'hui les hôtels campanile vous
offre 5000 francs plus nécessaire de
voyage campanile
mon cher jean marc j'en connais qui
passe un bon dimanche l'un est très bon
tout va bien pour vous c'est à vous vous
les avez gagné cet acquis à qui acquit
j'avoue mais je veux dire que c'est
vraiment à vous et moi je vous féliciter
personnellement je trouve que c'est pas
suffisant moi aussi j'ai une question
bonus à vous poser c'est un document
qu'on va vous montrer un document
brouillé cryptée qui va durer vingt
secondes six boules identifié ce
document vous gagnerez le bonus 3000
francs en fait à part les hôtels grille
campanile vous êtes prêts jean-marc
attention question bonus
document brouillé 20 secondes tab images
c'est le film l'ours de jean jacques
annaud
[Musique]
pas du tout ça n'est pas un extrait du
film l'ours de jean jacques annaud c'est
la naissance d'un enfant tout simplement
f aol alors on en reste là vous en
restez à avec vos 5000 francs ce qui est
déjà pas si mal
j'ai une dernière bonne nouvelle pour
vous on a rendez vous dimanche prochain
est ce que vous serez notre invité pour
un autre numéro de pied du mur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]